I know you can't do this forever to save
people make them see they're better
sounds hey everybody you've all been
asking for a more spoilery Justice
League review so we'll be talking about
specific things for the movie the Whedon
of it all the Snyder of it all what I
feel like they did to the movie in
post-production because it does feel
like this was originally intended to be
a very different story and just through
reshoots and edits they completely
changed it for some specific reasons so
also try to provide a timeline because
the story of the making of the movie is
just as fascinating as the actual movie
itself but if you are finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'm doing the ticket giveaway
still I'll explain at the end of the
video but I'll just start out by saying
that I think the movie did exactly what
it needed to do so regardless of box
office regardless of what critics think
about it it accomplished its goal so I
think that no matter how much money it
makes Warner Brothers is happy with the
finished product now you also have to be
honest there are some clear flaws with
the film visibly noticeable problems the
mustache gate if at all some of the CG
problems then there's the narrative
problems because of the way they edited
it trying to keep it under two hours
this feels like it should have been a
four hour movie so you chopped almost
half of your movie out of course there's
going to be narrative problems but I
want to start off with the really good
stuff and that's really where you get to
the middle part of the film once the
heroes all come together because that's
when the film really picks up and I feel
like part of the reason why Warner
Brothers is like please edit out you
know this much of the film get it under
two hours we just want to get to the fun
stuff
they probably test Joss Whedon during
the reshoots and the edits to get the
Justice League together much much faster
like get them together so we can do the
fun stuff that will have a big action
set piece we really want people to get
invested with these characters so that
no matter how this film does they're
excited to see these characters come
back in other films so like I said I
actually think that that was successful
it's just that when you start poking
holes and like you know why was the
ending this way why did it look this way
why did Henry Cavill face look like this
that kids
into some of the deeper flaws of the
film so we'll talk about that in a
second but between the reshoots in the
Wonder Woman movie and the stuff that
they shopped before Wonder Woman came
out her character still felt fairly
consistent albeit the way she was shot
was very different the camera treated
her in a very different way than it did
in Wonder Woman so like a really good
example as a Zack Snyder you can tell
had a bunch of ass shots of Wonder Woman
so if you like the really gratuitous
Wonder Woman stuff there's a lot of that
in this film like I think I've ended up
using this frame of her just because
it's really cool to see her throw that
guy in slow motion and it's a great
action scene I think this is a Zack
Snyder shot because there is very
prominent Wonder Woman ass so that just
gets to some of Zack Snyder strengths
you know however you feel about him as a
filmmaker he is fantastic with visuals
so like you know you read the Dark
Knight Returns and then you see Batman V
Superman you're like wow he really did
try to do this comic book but then we
get to Ezra Miller's flash probably one
of the more important things to talk
about because flashpoint is gonna be
such a big movie coming up I'll talk
about that in a separate video because
that gets into some of the universe
edits and changes that they might make
to characters some of that still up in
the air they've confirmed a few things
like Batman will be a big part of it so
I will talk about Ben Affleck in his
future as Batman but as a character Ezra
Miller actually did work really well I
liked his performance but you can tell
there are a lot of jokes and funny
moments that Whedon gave to his
character that didn't always land
because it would feel like he was in a
different movie from some of the other
characters because I think a lot of the
scenes with the flash actually standing
still and talking to people are all from
the Whedon reshoots like there's a lot
of flash that was cut out of this movie
iris West used to be in the movie they
cut her out they cut a bunch of other
moments from the trailer that you've
seen with him out it's the same thing
for the other characters too like I said
they cut out about 50 minutes of the
movie so naturally you're gonna lose
some characters along the way but I feel
like he did a good job of balancing Ben
Affleck's Batman character out he
balanced cyborg really well who wasn't
so much of a character as he was a
MacGuffin in this fell like he was
really important for the plot but
there's also a ton of cyborg scenes that
got cut out so you kind of introduced to
him then you learn why he's important
and then he helps them pull the mother
boxes apart and that's the end of cyborg
that's all you get of him but I do think
that ray Fisher worked better on screen
than I expected him to like a lot of the
early CG seemed pretty raw and by the
end of the film he was getting that more
comic book II looking version of the
costume so I think that they'll be able
to fix some of the CG problems in the
performance capture problems with cyborg
because there were some moments
on-screen where he's standing next to
the other characters in the physics just
look really weird it's the same thing
with Steppenwolf so the next big
important character Jason Momoa so
obviously very important because Aquaman
is gonna be the next movie that we see
so it was really important that they
sold this character Jason Momoa is
incredibly entertaining I feel like he
totally sold the character albeit the
story of his character is chopped up
quite a bit so I understand if you're
confused about a lot of the stuff that
was happening in Atlantis I will do
separate videos about that because I
think they just cut that out and they're
like we'll deal with that when we get to
the Aquaman movie Willem Dafoe was
playing volcko he'll come back during
the Aquaman movie he actually had scenes
in Justice League that were cut out but
I think will be great he's this big
tough guy they use him for comedy I
think it totally works especially those
moments where they're together in the
middle part of the film and he's just
like this is a terrible plan I think
we're all gonna die I'm telling you you
bring him back he comes back wrong like
all the characters do a good job with
the setup for the return of Superman the
jokes totally worked there's the flash
Pet Sematary line Aquaman gets a version
of that too he's gonna come back wrong
naturally when he does come back and
they're all facing him there yep he came
back wrong I told you guys this be a bad
idea but then probably the other most
important performance in the film was
Henry Cavill so everybody's like what's
the deal with Superman what's going on
most people are talking about the
mustache of things rather than his
actual performance but just to talk
about the performance first so he gets a
big personality change so the way
they're billing this version of the
character is that he's the truest
version of Superman the comic-book
Superman not the one that you saw during
Man of Steel who had to think about it
for a little while before he was sure he
wanted to save the human race do I want
to save them okay yeah I'll go defeat
Zod and save them but by the end of the
film they get to the point where you
know he rips the trenchcoat open and
it's like yeah you know comic book
Superman is here so it'll be interesting
to see where they take him in future
because it's probably going to be at
least three or four years before we get
the next Man of Steel film there's no
script no director the producers on
Justice League said that there were a
couple of story concepts but that's
about it they just have concepts there's
no script without a script they can't
hire a director they can't get things
going so it's gonna be at least three
years because it usually takes about a
year to get the script done but Ben
Affleck's Batman is another big
character that goes through a
personality change one of the funniest
Batman moments in any film was in that
big final action set piece where
Superman comes to save the day in Batman
shows his full-blown fangirl face like
remember when the flash fangirled on
Superman at the monument when he first
came back like oh my god this is so
amazing it's like Jesus came back from
the dead
Batman has a slightly more subtle
version of that when they're getting
their asses handed to them by
Steppenwolf and then boom all of a
sudden Superman comes back to turn the
tide but it's just so funny to see him
make this face just a couple movies
after he was making this face trying to
kill Superman but getting into the
moustache of things so everybody's like
what is the deal with the uncanny valley
face so you may or may not know about
the reshoots situation in the timing of
Mission Impossible Six Henry Cavill is
the villain of Mission Impossible six
they mandated that he had to wear a
mustache for that role but originally
they had planned for that so he was
going to finish shooting Mission
Impossible six before they started doing
the Justice League issues everything had
been fine but then Warner Brothers
basically saw the movie that they had in
the situation with Zack Snyder came up
he had to lead four very unfortunate
reasons so it required more extensive
reshoots so that is really where the
scheduling problems happen in paramount
the people that make the Mission
Impossible movies said you're not
allowed to shave this mustache so that
is how you get to uncanny valley face
Superman because they had to just
digitally remove it I can't imagine how
many millions of dollars Warner Brothers
had to spend to remove that mustache but
the thing about that is is that now when
you see the uncanny valley face you know
that that is from the reshoot so it's a
little bit easier to tell what stuff
came from Zack Snyder and what stuff
came from Joss Whedon but even though it
can be very distracting and I don't
think that they'll be able to
fix it for the DVD release I do think
that the film is so incredibly enjoyable
and obviously like I said the whole idea
is just to get you invested in the
characters more so than was the original
intention to tell this big dark Side
Story
so this is where you get into the
Franken movie of it all which is why
it's getting dinged by critics so much
because it does feel like a Franken
movie but I'll talk a little bit more
about what I think the original movie
was like the Zack Snyder plan for the
universe when I do my deleted scenes
video because originally there's just
like so much lead up before the
characters actually come together and I
think when Warner Brothers came in and
said keep this under two hours just get
the team together as fast as possible
that's really where you have the massive
story changes and then the different
ending to be a more finite
self-contained thing because the other
big thing that they changed was the tone
so I think the original ending of the
film was more of an injustice ii moment
where Superman rips out Steppenwolf's
heart just like you see him doing this
panel from the Joker that's what Zack
Snyder does he does comic book panel so
this just a theory but the original
ending of the film was very different in
what's the big thing that you notice
about the way this film ends is that
unlike doomsday they don't kill the
villain the villain is actually taken
away because he feels fear back to
Darkseid so I think that no kill rule is
a change that they made late in the game
and it just requires them to change the
ending of the film and the Russian
family as well that's also a Whedon
thing too and it feels like it's
reactionary because Superman literally
leaves that final battle mid-fight to go
save people and I originally don't think
that he did that I think people were
like how come Superman doesn't care more
about people so that's where you get
into reshoots where you sort of redefine
who Superman is and who these characters
are and I think in addition to making
the film funnier making the characters
work together a little bit better Joss
Whedon try to add in some more human
stakes which is where you get your
Russian family so that was sort of a
late addition to the film but the thing
about the movie is is they actually
started shooting it right as Batman V
Superman was hitting theaters which
means that Zack Snyder had planned out
most of these big visuals beforehand so
that's why in some of the big action set
pieces where flash will have a joke that
may not
or Superman has a joke at the end where
he's like I want to die and it just
doesn't feel quite like it land is
really we didn't try to mix tone with
what Zack Snyder was originally trying
to do with the battle itself so it's
like okay they all run around they fight
the villains here how do we work in some
character moments to that that's where
Joss Whedon comes in so there can be
moments where you can feel the two
different tones of the film at war with
each other like oh this was originally
probably a really dark scene but just
overall my ranking of the film since
having seen it a couple times hasn't
changed that much ranking from my least
favorite two most favorite DC EU films
it's still Suicide Squad Batman V
Superman then Justice League and Man of
Steel almost tied and then Wonder Woman
so final report on the film is that the
characters all work great together and I
would like to see them again you know
who knows that they make the swap with
Ben Affleck they just need to spend more
time working on the story and be more
consistent in the tone from start to
finish and not trying to change the film
halfway down the road the thing about
the end too is that Jesse Eisenberg for
the brief moment that you see him on
screen does seem like he's embracing the
more comic book II aspect of the
character so if he's gonna play it that
way I'll be totally fine with it just as
long as he doesn't hog too much screen
time
but along with Man of Steel and Wonder
Woman I think that it'll be one of the
more rewatchable DC EU films and that's
really how the film stands the test of
time like how much do you want to
re-watch it but what'll happen is I'll
do my first Easter Egg video tomorrow or
Monday then I'll do deleted scenes and
then I'll start talking about Flash
flashpoint changes in the future of the
Batman character I have a pretty good
idea of what Matt Reeves is gonna do
with his Batman film but that's still a
ways off like that could be a couple
years before we see it so we'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Knight striker please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I'll
announce a new winner when I post my
next DC video you can click here for my
post credit scene video and you can
click here for the new trailer or the
four-way crossover thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight